one of the gentlemen that's uh in the
submersible gentleman by the name of pH
nargley uh worked with him over the last
30 years he was one of our dive Masters
um at RMS and he's just a all-around
good guy
well I I mean you know we we've been
salvaging uh artifacts from the Titanic
for the last 25 years plus
um and if you're set up for the mission
I mean we'll usually spend a year year
and a half planning uh Salvage operation
to recover artifacts to recover
different pieces uh from the Titanic and
this is not something that you can throw
together in you know 48 hours plus you
have to mobilize equipment you have to
get equipment out there and I'm not sure
there's anything close enough that can
actually get down to Titanic's depth
to uh to do any good if that is actually
where the submersible is
when we're diving in the mirrors uh the
Russian subs or the nautil the French
submersible they're just like the
American Alvin you know there is a
transponder system that's set up it's a
it's a net that we navigate in so that
we know where we are at all times on the
wreck of Titanic
um we're in constant communication with
the vessel up top and it just makes it
for a much uh safer environment
um I understand this vessel you know it
gets put on a sled and
dumped in the water and their only
navigation is uh you know from the
support ship up top and I don't
I don't uh adhere to that
myself personally and of course that's
just a personal opinion but
I I don't I don't think that's uh the
way it should be done